[Musique]
durant les vacances scolaires mascar un
jardin botanique de la Réunion propose
divers ateliers et animations pour les
petits 40 enfants de l'association
Atelier marmaille de Saint-Louis s'y
sont rendus afin de découvrir les
différentes espèces indigènes et
exotiques du jardin alors les ateliers
marmaille depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois proposent divers actions en
direction de la valorisation de
l'identité réonnaise son patrimoine son
sa culture son identité et c'est vrai
qu'on prend plaisir à aller se balader
de jardin botanique en en
sentier plein de petites actions comme
ça qui font en sorte d'apporter un socle
où les enfants peuvent s'approprier leur
environnement pour pouvoir se construire
et à leur tour apporter des choses à à
cette à ce beau territoire rignonnais
l'année 2016 a été déclarée Année
internationale des légumineuses par les
Nations Unies les enfants ont participé
à une chasse au trésor sur ce thème ils
ont également fabriqué un petit pot
végétal dans lequel ils ont semé une
graine de voem graines comestibles
appartenant à la famille des
légumineuses c'est donc l'année
internationale des légumineuses on va
essayer de leur faire découvrir les
trésors de ces plantes savoir que les
légumineuses donc c'est une une famille
botanique de touteses espèces qui donne
des gousses alors certaines sont
comestibles d'autres non et nous donc on
a prévu une grande chasse au trésors
pour leur faire découvrir les
légumineuses du jardin et faire un focus
sur les légumineuses les grains qui ont
eu et qui ont toujours un rôle
extrêmement important sur l'île objectif
c'est de leur confier une une une une
pratique de une leur confier une
technique longtemps en fait de
construction de de peau et de leur faire
planter une légumineuse justement pour
qu'il puissent repartir donc
effectivement chez avec le pot et
ramener un souvenir de leur de leur
passage à Mascarin des enfants tous
assdus et très intéressé par cet atelier
ils se sont investis tout au long de la
matinée dans la découverte des
différentes espèces appartenant à la
famille des légumineus là on a fait on a
fait des petits
po avec des feuilles après on a attaché
là il fa une chasse au trésor déjà vous
trés j'ai bien aimé
on fait une chasse au trésor et on a
planté des choses on découvre des
plantes on fait plein de choses un
atelier ludique qui sensibilise les
enfants à la diversité des espèces
comestibl qui ont marqué la vie des
[Musique]
réonnés